so there's a little update here on well
a couple things
you know who commented and i confirmed
that it's legit
somebody you know commented on our
sherman clip
um sherman's cousin female
cousin commented on it and uh let me
read to you what i don't know
what she said no it's quite it's not
what you think
her cut his cousin and it is i i've done
i've did the legwork
my brother mentioned sherman drank
energy drinks a lot on top of alcohol
so if this is true i'm heartbroken for
my aunt and uncle
and they have to bury their firstborn i
pray for sherman's soul earl is a
horrible person
that's pretty funny that's um cousin
and uh so he's he had to have done drugs
there's no
when they go like we drink a lot of
energy drinks too and booze it's like
42 he was either chugging rotgut
or he was doing something else i mean he
also was really into boxing and stuff
and maybe
he probably did a lot of maybe did roids
too when he was younger right maybe
and he doesn't strike me as the kind of
guy that would have done them in a swim
in the right way
yeah he probably was just jamming
needles you're probably doing the pills
yeah and stuff you know yeah so um
we have a new video when we we that we
have a new video here
and uh well first off i want to read a
facebook post that i i sent to you
uh this is from kade dorian paradoxa
which is you know
we all know is uh earl also known
as dayton hypernova uh he posted this
two days ago
the inauguration is already going on
guess i'm watching it it's strange to
not be watching all of this around my
older brother who was literally shouting
heavyweight champion of the world
as mike pence was being inaugurated four
years ago
i recorded that with the camera directly
out i always thought after i moved out i
would use that footage to incriminate
him
um what charge since his face was right
on the camera
he was so serious seriously obsessed
with boxing other races of men and
gender types
so he was planning to incriminate his
brother who is now dead
forcing uh heavyweight champ of the
world to mike pence now
as you know they live across the street
from his sister his sister lives across
the street from him with her black
husband
black husband's is a manga guy is a
right-wing dude we've talked about it
before
um i'll spare you the beginning of this
because the beginning of this it's hard
to hear but it's just his family talking
about politics
and uh talking about the n-word and all
that stuff that's what it is so
uh i'm gonna kick in right here where
where dayton steps in ready
here we go so you hear that just talking
down there whatever
um and here you go
i guess i'm recording this right now
because
uh i think i i guess i'm recording this
right now just because i think it's
extremely ironic that they're having
a minorities discussion downstairs my
family are down there all decisions and
our
black neighbors down there um
our religious right-wing black papers
down there
okay you know the token black friend
i love by the way now he's the token
black friend
i love this is this is what the [ __ ]
this is how these people always think
they
they really i know it's such a a cliche
thing to say democrats are the real
racists but
they say the most racist [ __ ]
unironically all the time oh yeah oh
your toe oh your uncle tom
token black friend and it's like jesus
christ like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with oh i'm sorry
somebody voted republican i guess you're
a fake black guy
uncle tom why don't you go back to the
[ __ ] slave days huh
why don't you go back to being a [ __ ]
slave and it's like
dude chill [ __ ] just doesn't vote for
this guy
yeah our religious right-wing black
papers down there
uh you know the token black friend of
the family
basically it's the only black friend
there now
i know this because i've spoken to
people in the lgbtq community and didn't
do
in delhi i know but in dayton and
they hate earl we've talked about like
the lgbt group in dayton hates earl
earl has no friends
black white or anything in between
and they're all talking down there about
minority
politics and i'm up here this woman
hiding in my bedroom woman hiding in his
bedroom would you feel sorry for him
but here's the thing right because i've
lived in houses and i've lived in like
even roommate situations or you lived
with family where
you you're not getting along with people
or whatever right
just the thought dayton it's crazier
i'll be like you could just leave you
could go out
not even move out which we know you're
never know just leave outside you could
just go for a walk
you could go you know i'll give you a
[ __ ] little bit of freebie advice
there earl
uh when i was broke and i wanted to get
out of my house for a few hours
i would go find a coffee shop that lets
you have refills
for either cheap or very you know
sometimes free
and then you go there and you read a
book and you keep having your coffee and
you
have a couple cigarettes and you zone
out for a little bit
and then you go home and things die down
it's very simple i was a kid in
a house where wild crazy abusive [ __ ]
happened you know what i do
just get on my bike go for a ride you
know what i mean go
hang out in front of the store get a get
a coca-cola
and just hang out you could do that earl
so rob goes wait
he has to have friends he had a birthday
party with catering of one medium pizza
catering
i hate that he used the word catering
haters
with i'm just picturing i'm closing my
eyes and picturing that one medium one
topic
just sitting and you know what the worst
part is birthday party catered
you know what his one topping was extra
cheese
i i will [ __ ] it dude when you only have
one topping and you wasted on that i'll
[ __ ]
blast you right in your stomach in my
blacked out bedroom
to show that no one's in here
he always like points out how he's
choosing to do all this weird [ __ ]
yeah but then assigning the blame to
these other people like
everybody downstairs is just they're
probably having a couple sandwiches
they're having lunch
and they're having an n-word discussion
which by the way when you have a black
person and some white people and you're
having
they're literally doing what this entire
country should be doing right now which
is just having a nice calm dialogue
having lunch and go
well i personally i'm not that bothered
by the word because i don't consider
myself that
can i have some more potential yeah well
that's mature but you know
these people nowadays they can't handle
it no i agree i agree pop
hey could i have some more coleslaw and
just hanging out having a night and he's
going
psychopaths that's why i'm in my darked
out room because i can't handle it
i can't handle it and everybody
downstairs is remember that one time
when they were eating
outside and he was filming this yes and
it literally looked like they were
having the nicest day
like the sister and her boyfriend
brought the kids over
and the kids were playing remember who
was the one with the black brother
hey earlier
he was like he froze up oh [ __ ] they saw
me and he's like literally just going
hey bud you know you want to come down
and get something to eat yeah we got
some hot dogs and [ __ ]
oh god jesus christ oh god
my blacked out bedroom to show
that no one's in here in solidarity with
black lives matter
because these people have harassed and
beaten me
and belittled they intrigued rob gavigan
i'm locked in my room wearing a dress
surrounded by eight grand worth of
tinfoil because they're the crazy ones
yes that's you just summarize yeah if
somebody needed to write
the the the pitch line for a movie like
remember they always had like the tag
line for a movie
that you just wrote the tagline for the
earl earl
[ __ ] uh biopic some people are saying
some new people who the hell is this
person
i recommend you going over to the clip
channel youtube.com rotc media and just
type in and search for
dayton hypernova and there's an entire
saga it's too much too
it is way too much to tell you right now
this is a very unwell trune that we were
proud to be the ones that brought to the
internet and he has been
he has just been something else we've
been covering this dude now for a long
time
and he has not changed here
so don't bother because these people
have harassed
and beaten me and belittled me so now
it's them
yeah so now that sherman's gone now
they've beat you i think you never said
they beat you before
you always said they tolerated sherman
beating you you see you never once said
that they beat you but now that he's
dead and you don't have that victim
point anymore now they're beating you am
i getting this right
so this is um somebody brought a
book a good question and i'm sure you've
received this question too
does everyone have to update their their
date and hypernova bingo cards
because my brother beats me is not
something you can really have in the
card
he used to beat him but it's not new but
now i think we're figuring it out
they beat me he doesn't have a villain
and you know somebody left a comment on
the clip channel
uh one of the hypernov videos he goes
people think this is the end of dayton
this is just the beginning
because now he doesn't have his brother
to blame or trump to blame because trump
is gone too
he doesn't have any villains so now it's
gonna be it's gonna be a fascinating
thing to see
who the new villains are in his story
yeah because he won't look inward he'll
actually invent something
yeah that's his [ __ ] problem of
course they'll be a new villain
but yeah i think what we need to do with
the bingo card is whatever the card was
that was my brother beats me
obviously we have to retire that square
but i say we make
what we'll do is we'll replace that with
something and then what we'll do is
we'll make the free square in the middle
the the free the free spot we'll just
have a picture of sherman with a halo
boom and always in honor of he beats me
in this house
in honor of my brother skinhead brother
beats me sherman will still
remain on the bingo card and be
remembered in perpetuity
uh with a little halo like george no
one's in here
so don't bother because these people
have harassed
and beaten me and belittled me
and treated me like [ __ ] for all the
reasons they're talking about the same
stuff hey earl
i don't know if you know this or not but
they also let you live in their house
for free and give you
walk-around money 100 a week to do a
chore that honestly is the world's
easiest chore
it's the chore that like even the
laziest piece of [ __ ] human being in the
world usually doesn't mind doing
right like laundry is the one that even
when you're lazy you're like
yeah just throw a load in us play video
games a little bit go back down and when
you throw it overloaded when it beeps
you move it to the dryer and you put the
new one in that's it yeah i have a
laundry room i have to walk to it's
still
i'd like bang it throw it in go back up
play some [ __ ] gta
that's about time go down gin the dryer
go back play some gta it's over
you get paid for that and then on top of
it
i love how he goes like they belittle me
they treat me like [ __ ] they do
if you were in a situation where your
family wasn't in
enabling you and taking care of you
you would have to go out into the real
world earl where everyone belittles you
and everyone treats you like [ __ ] drive
on i-4 during rush hour everyone hates
you and wants to kill you
you know what i mean go to the go to
[ __ ] walmart when they're
closing in an hour on a friday everyone
there it's every man for himself
people are gonna call you the gay f slur
and a dress wearing and a [ __ ]
that's your life that's just the way it
is just like people are gonna call me a
fat
racist skinhead whatever it is there's
somebody out there who's gonna say mean
words to you so
you gotta you gotta plow through what's
he gonna do when his parents are dead
because they're both very old rob kevin
goes they're not skin heads earl
they're going through chemotherapy he
said they brought me to this building
the other day and it was full of
skinheads and they were all it was scary
because they were all skinheads there
was a whole building from them and
you're like it's a cancer ward it was an
oncologist's office
i don't know what you're doing i don't
treat me like [ __ ] for all the reasons
they're talking about the same stuff
down there about races
and i'm a trans person and none of them
are acting with any sense of
responsibility where do you think this
started
uh i don't know man he looks like he's
probably been doing it since he
from what i at least from we've gathered
from the videos he's been doing this
since he's lived there his whole life
since
i think he's this is the way he's always
been i mean
yeah but no but i mean at some point he
was a dude and had a girlfriend i could
tell you that
yeah and at some point he was a
nine-year-old kid that just liked to run
around and play on his bike
like this this stuff comes in either and
this kind of mental illness either
creeps in it
in your teen years or in your late teen
years or in your early 20s
it's as you get older the likelihood
that it's going to
slip in uh is is increased but
i'm really curious like where
where the divergence happened like you
know because his parents have to
probably think back and go
remember when he was 13 and he started
just spiraling over the tiniest things
and not letting things go
we should have known then like this guy
definitely
i hate him i hate him so much i hate him
more than anyone we cover on this show
i'm a trans person and none of them are
acting with any sense of responsibility
in the exact same context about a
different demographic
from any of them
but what do you mean a different
demographic you just mentioned at the
video they're talking to a
black guy exact same context
not only talking to a black guy they're
letting their
son daughter whatever
live in their house about a different
demographic
from any of them
my face is very visible here so just
this is sad oh it is sad but not for the
reasons you think
not for the reasons you think
i you know it's funny like early on i
used to flip-flop between feeling bad
for this guy and hating him and it's
just become
all hate oh yeah i despise this dude